- [Narrator] Salty, sweet, chewy, crunchy.
It's a delicious combination born
from one of Black America's most
consequential cultural movements.
It was the 1930s.
The place was New York City.
It was the epicenter of Black American's
movement into mainstream culture.
The Harlem Renaissance.
Artists, writers, and thinkers
would gather at venues
in Harlem until the wee
hours of the morning.
Listening to touring big
bands and jazz artists.
As the clubs stayed open later and later,
so did the local restaurants to
take in the hungry concert-goers.
One such restaurant owner
was Joseph T. Wells,
founder of Well's Supper Club.
Well's became known for
its Southern-inspired menu.
But Wells needed a hit to stay on top of
the 2 a.m. restaurant business.
What could he do?
Seeing an opportunity, Wells realized that
the fried chicken leftovers from dinner
could be served with the freshly prepared
waffles for breakfast.
Creating a sweet and savory concoction
unlike anything else.
The dish was a hit.
Eventually, word got out
and chicken and waffles
became a soul food staple
from Atlanta to Los Angeles.
And though Well's closed in 1982,
the dish lives on.
So, when you think of
the Harlem Renaissance,
take Duke Ellington's jazz,
Langston Hughes's poetry,
and Joseph T. Wells' chicken and waffles.